JAMES CLEWETT: Absolutely
it's heavy.
It is an antique 1980s
television.
This is back from when
television was furniture.
I love it.
Well, this is my
first computer.
This is a computer that my
parents had the foresight to
buy me when I was
11 years old.
It gave me a curiosity about
mathematics and physics, which
has never really gone away.
Today I'm going to talk
about the number 15.
And I want to tell you that if
you're a computer geek like
me, we don't really think
of the number 15 as 15.
We think of it as the
letter F, and I'm
going to tell you why.
Right, you've got to
get this sound.
This just makes such a fantastic
switch-on sound.
[BEEP]
Isn't that satisfying?
So all I'm going to do is write
a short piece of code
that makes the computer count.
I'm rather pleased with myself
that I can still remember how
to do this.
Tah-dah!
So all I'm doing is just
counting 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, and then something
rather odd happens.
And instead of counting to 10,
the computer switches to A, B,
C, D, E, F, and then 10.
11, 12, 13.
And again it happens at 19.
1A, 1B, C, D, E, F. 20.
How bizarre.
I was baffled.
I was 11 years old, and we used
to have to wait for games
to load from cassettes.
And when they loaded, they would
count, and that would
take maybe 10 minutes.
And so I would be watching
these numbers count, very
patiently waiting to play
Pac-Man or Tetris or whatever
game I was playing that day, and
wondering precisely why it
wasn't just getting on with
it and getting to 10.
You know, why did it have to
go through-- it felt like
torture, because I wanted
to play the game.
Get on with it.
Count to 10.
But no, we had to go A through
F, first of all.
So what we need to remember is
that computers don't count the
way you and I count
on our fingers.
They count on lines representing
ones and zeroes,
binary numbers.
So what I want to show you is
just four lines, first of all,
and the number 0, the number 1,
the number 2, the number 3.
And then I'm going
to skip a few.
Down here we're going to
go to the number 14.
And the number 15.
OK, so there's quite a few
numbers in between, which we
skipped over for brevity.
So this is 0, 1, 2, 3, 14, 15.
And I have to stop there.
I have to stop there because
we've run out of numbers.
If I try and count to a higher
number, that means that's got
to be 0, 0, 0, 0, 1.
But I don't have space
for this one here.
And so we can't count
to a number bigger
than 15 on four bits.
The thing is, if you want to
understand the underlying ones
and zeroes that's going on in a
computer, then I need to be
able to very quickly say
what is this number?
And this number, unfortunately,
bears very
little relationship to
the decimal value.
So, for example, the number
9, this is the
number 9 for a computer.
So the number 11, that's
number 11, OK?
Or the number 6, for example,
would be 0, 1, 1, 0, number 6.
So what we do instead is we
count in a thing called
hexadecimal.
This is base 16.
So if we had 16 fingers, then
we would have come up with
numbers sufficient to
go from 1 to 16.
But because we only have 10
fingers, we only have 10
digits for counting.
And so instead of using just
more digits, we used letters
to replace the missing digits.
So let's start at the
number 8, and we'll
work our way through.
So the number 8 is going
to be 1, 0, 0, 0.
That's 8.
The number 9, 1, 0, 0, 1.
That's 9.
And then the number
10, that's 10.
Now, notice that in decimal,
we've had to go into a new
column for the number 10.
But if we're working in
hexadecimal, then this is 8,
9, and then this becomes
the letter a.
And then 11, that's 11,
and it's the letter b.
Then we're just going to skip to
the end, and it's going to
be 1, 1, 1, 1, which is the
number 15, or in our case, the
letter f, our magic number.
OK, this is magic because it
allows us as programmers to
very quickly see what's going
on with the binary numbers,
the electronics inside
the computer.
So in an 8-bit computer, we've
got two sets of 4-bit sets.
So the number 0 becomes 0,
0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0.
Two lots of four bits.
Now, this set can be represented
by one hexadecimal
digit, the letter 0.
And just to let you know that
it's hexadecimal, I'm just
going to write an X
in front of it.
And this lot can similarly
be represented by the
hexadecimal number 0.
So this is 10, and this is 10.
But in hexadecimal, we can
still represent this by a
single character.
This becomes a, and
this becomes a.
In hexadecimal, our number is a,
a, with a little x in front
of it, just to tell you that
it's a hexadecimal number.
So I'm going to skip to the crux
of the issue, and that is
the top number that we can
store in an 8-bit value,
which, of course, is simply
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
MALE SPEAKER: What
number is that?
JAMES CLEWETT: And
that number is--
this is f.
This is f.
So we've got the hexadecimal
number ff, which is equal to
255, which is the highest
value that an 8-bit
computer can store.
OK, now, course, modern
computers aren't
simply eight bits long.
Recently, 32 bits, or you can
go out and you can buy a
top-end 64-bit computer.
So I want to show you the
highest number in very
shorthand notation that a 32-bit
computer can store.
Here we go.
ff, ff, ff, ff, so 8 bits, 16
bits, 24 bits, 32 bits.
Now I'll write that in binary.
How I hate you.
1111, 1111, 1111, 1111, 1111--
I'm going to have to put
a few on the front.
And that is the binary number 1,
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1,
1, 1, 1, 1.
You get the idea.
It's a big number.
And that's why we don't
use binary.
We use hexadecimal values.
Obviously, if I wanted to write
a really big number
down, it's just too much
pen and ink, so we
don't use the binary.
We don't use decimal because,
well, this number, it's not
65,000, it's approximately
4 billion.
This has no relationship
to 4 billion.
There's no obvious way to tie
the two things together.
But when we're using the
hexadecimal numbers, each
character is simply tied to a
block of four binary values.
So this character represents the
first four, this character
the next four.
And so it's very easy to just
walk along, understanding the
number in human readable
chunks.